[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Robert winow and I'm a go
Enthusiast I'm a Consulting developer I
try to help startups with their scaling
and launching problems and along the way
I pied up a fair good to
go uh I'm also getting over a cold so if
I stop and cough forgive me and if I get
quiet say something if I'm too loud say
something and finally I love questions
so please feel free to ask them
anytime we're going to talk about today
uh are the basics of cialization and why
you should be excited about
cialization why you might need another
serialization format what makes flat
buer special and some examples on how to
use it
so a serialization format can take many
forms it's pretty
General examples are Jason protol
buffers Thrift XML and a lot a lot of
other
ones question who here spends time
working serialized data raise your
hands oh trick question everybody
does serialization is is a way of
specifying what data means without that
you just have sequences of Rights so we
all work with civilization formats all
the time for
everything but there already a lot of
them why would we need a new
one turns out that at Google Android
game developers need a better way to
store their data games are actually
demanding applications even though we
have Angry Birds things like that we
also have uh all sorts of very heavy 3D
you know first person shooter type games
and it turns out that moving data around
can be a huge bottleneck especially on
phones anytime that you uh allocate an
object on Android on the jbm creat just
a little bit of friction existing
formats like protocol buffers create a
lot of objects and we'll get to that in
a
minut so the primary alternative for
these Android developers was to use
protocol buffers which is
reasonable who here has used protocol
buffers great yeah so uh hugely popular
and they've been around a
while and there a lot of good things
about them they're robust they're secure
they've been audited completely very
popular and just like with with IBM
nobody ever got fired for picking
protocol
however they have a number of
shortcomings they allocate many objects
in the process of parsing
data they don't let you randomly access
your data so even if you have an array
like structure in the macro you don't
get to index into that in constant
time as a consequence they have poor
data
locality so the question was can we talk
about data locality a little bit so it
turns out that the way CPUs in memory
are related these days the CPUs are much
much
faster uh in memory and so the crucial
bottleneck is how do you feed this
monstrous processing Engine with enough
data to keep it
busy the best way to do that is to keep
data in line effectively in Array so
anytime you violate that anytime you
require access to another part of ram
you have to load it into the cache on
the CPU and uh it causes
stalls so avoiding that is key to memory
performance so the kind of the moral
there is if you can lay it out like an
array it'll be good and what happens is
you sort of stream across the array and
you always keep the CPU full
for very large code base protocol
buffers weighs in almost 4 megab of
code and they are slow relatively
speaking and finally I've heard rumors
uh you know I can't really substantiate
this but Google spends Google spends
millions of
dollars NBA
censorship not
popular so I put rumors that Google
spends millions of dollars every year
serializing and deserializing
protocols and you might say oh well
that's just because they have to new
computers well yeah sure but the order
of magnitude is much higher than maybe
in theory should be um you say um 3.8
gab of code for the protocol bu code
base is that the code for like the
compiler for it or the size of the code
that actually injects into your program
time uh that is for the existing
code not the
generated
so there's this interesting little group
inside of Android which itself is inside
Google called the fun propulsion lab and
they get to make tools for game
developers and I think the point of them
is to facilitate game development so
that the ecosystem on Android gets
better and they went out of Limb and and
decided to try a new
approach what it be possible to build a
serialization format that's simple you
still get schema version for your data
you can access it randomly like an array
and it's really really
fast yeah you can they tried and they
did it and it's called Flat
buffers so here are some micro
benchmarks from the flat buffers
website and I'll I'll just go through
them line by line because I think
they're very exciting so uh you can see
uh on the second line of this it says
protocol buffers you do about 3,300
operations a second in this micro
Benchmark and it takes 302 micr seconds
to do each
operation flat buffers in contrast takes
NS you can do over a thousand times more
reads per second with FL buers and
buers any questions I'm not
done all right so we're going to talk
about how they do that so it's a new
standard it's an open source project
from Google that came out last year and
it's created and maintained by wer van
erson who's right up here and you should
talk to them whenever you want after the
talk and it's got a great open source
lense so the big idea behind flat
buffers is that they're just statically
typed schema version portable
strs there a way to lay out data in
memory on a file and interpret it in a
very lightweight
manner so I I can never lose by quoting
Rock he says rule five data dominates if
you chose the right data structures and
organize things well the algorithms
would almost always be self-evident data
structures not algorithms are Central to
programming have any of you seen this
notion
before
so let's talk about speed and how we get
it one thing is you know why do I bother
trying to make things faster computers
are really fast who
cares well it turns out orders of
attitude still really important if you
can figure out a way to use one10 the
number of computers to do a task that
would be in your cluster that's we doing
you do that a couple times all of a
sudden you can do one more thing Sly you
couldn't do before
flat buffers has a different philosophy
and uh it's designed from the bottom up
to be really
fast the way it does this is that on
read there are no memory allocations
there are no intermediate
objects uh we talked about data locality
earlier uh it's data is tightly packed
uh so it's very friendly to CPU data
caches and speaking of caches uh there's
minimal code on the execution pths for
reading data so instruction caches on
CPUs also can get polluted with too much
code
so the primary way flat buers works is
just by doing arithmetic on fighter
which you know most of us are very
familiar with but not in the
serialization
context when you're reading data in flat
buffers you have no calls to
Mal you let that a little bit I think
it's a very powerful idea in general you
can write software without po malic
you're on a good
path so motivating example number one
how would you serialize in ARR this is
going to be pretty simple but I think
it's interesting so an array is just a
sequence of fixed with elements you can
use pointer arithmetic to find what you
want so let's say we have an array of
the first four prime numbers 3 3 byes or
sorry 32 bits wide uh they look like
what's on the bottom here first one is 1
second sry 2 3 5 7 so you index into
that by saying oh here's four bytes four
bytes four byes four byes you do the
multiplication you land where you need
to be you interpret the next four byes
as your number and you're
done and in code you have a
buffer that holds those
bites you can write a function like this
get function here but assuming the data
is a little
endian you give it the offset you want
and then the bite buffer you calculate
I'm sorry you can the index ins you
calculate the offset you need which is
the width of the data type times the
index and then you can dive down into
unsa land and cast into value you
want it works so you get 0 1 2 three the
data
more interesting is a struct so a struct
is just a heterogenous group of fixed
width elements and again you can just
use point
[Music]
one any questions so
far great so let's say you had a struct
called particle as a position in a
threedimensional space and the
color 9 byes small you can encode it in
a bite buffer the first two byes one Z
is X the second two byes two 0 is y 3 0
Z and then
12812 is the
RGB to get X similarly to the previous
example you jump into the buffer you
pick the two bites you want it was an
in6 you cast it to the type you want and
you're
[Music]
done so for y just +
two and then Z plus 2
again are we all familiar with using
unsaved
pointers yeah okay it's okay if not and
finally uh so the RGB value has three
bytes and so the type is actually a 3
byray which is
distin great okay so just like these
things which are in memory and are
platform dependent and have Indian
indianness that varies across platforms
flat buffers takes that and standardizes
it but the idea is the same just uses
pointer okay let's get to the
code so here's a schema and imagine we
had a game player very
simple I'd like to slow down here and
make sure everybody understands what
this is specifying
so you you can construct a hierarchy of
object types primarily called tables
structs you give the names you can Nest
them variable like the way these
instruct and
tables but in the end you specify a base
type here it's the player more advanced
schemas you can players for example
could have uh
inventories you can have things that are
WS you can store all sorts of data
really anything you want
so to use this well first you've got to
compile the flaters compiler which is a
simple uh make and then you can use it
uh to create go code you run flat c-g
which specifies go code and then the
name of the schema it creates one little
file and this is interesting because the
code to generate the go code that you'll
use is written
C++ and so far we have generation code
for C++ go Java and
c and it's a tiny little file uh the
generated code in this instance is just
over a kiloby in
size and then we can use
it still a tiny bit of implementation
detail in here which I think we could do
some API recoring to remove but start
off by creating what's called a flat
buers Builder which is a management
object for creating a sequence of bites
that is interpreted as a flat
buer it's an implementation detail but
in fact variable length
vectors like strings need to be created
outside of their objects so first we
create a string which is my name broader
and that's going to be six bytes long
plus a terminating zero so seven in
total the next line we start we take our
generated code which is imported under
the name game and we we start a player
on the Builder and then we add the name
and we creat earlier and then we add
help and then we tell the Builder we're
done and then finally close the Builder
and what Builder has now is a set of
bites and we can take those bites and
write them to a file and that's all we
have to do so the last two lines fetch
those bites and then the final line
writes it to a play a file robert.
player and the size of that file is
pretty small it's only 40
bytes which is nice because you know if
you think about it we're not storing
that much information so it should be
commerate with how much we're storing it
is and then we can load it back up and
we can read it using our nice IO to
function and then we use the single game
get Rus player function which was
generated for us and then we can query
it and return items and health is
something that we said and name is
something that we
said any
questions yeah
so so the is you have ton of SE
C everything
AEV this
Frame the eror by
[Music]
generating concep
not so so the question if I have right
was that uh typically if you're doing
lowle cating you end up packing bites a
lot like this manually is it fair to say
that flat
buffers is a way to automatically will
create those bite packing
routines I absolutely think that's the
case and that it sort of lifts that into
a library and makes it affordable and U
you know easy for anyone to use in my
opinion so yeah that's exactly what it
is so I just want to show a little bit
what's in those 40 bytes so U this will
be a different talk but the flat weers
format includes things called V tables
which allow you to have deprecated
Fields default
[Music]
values at the beginning of this we have
eight bites that are dedicated to
telling us where the player object
exists in the file the next few bites
are metadata about our player object the
next few bites are where is the string
next to bites of Health that armor and
the string and we documents just 40
bites so I think this is a good example
of kind of bite packing that you're
talking about
I want I want to Echo uh what you're
saying so he's saying that this seems
almost what's the big deal here uh the
big deal is that it reduces by many
orders of magnitude the complexity to
serialize data and read it very fast
it's lightweight it's about as simple as
you could get the feature set that it
has
so it's very
exciting but I I
love so could you com on the fact that
so the order of the fields in this in
the code you wrote was made Health armor
but the order that there in there is
help name could you comment why that
is question basically why does named yet
I I believe it's because it's very so
the question is why why is it named in
line in the
object it's at the end well the reason
is because name can be as a variable
length uh set of bites so if you know
the size of your primary type which is a
player you can't also then have a
variable sized set of bites in it you in
fact have to reference it when it lives
elsewhere and so that's why the name
lives at the end it's because it's
actually outside of the object in the B
format
any other questions yeah you you
mentioned a lot about random access to
this data more the intended use case
something
or is
there netork
appli whereas buers be the solution for
that so the question is is this more for
sort of file based data or does it also
apply to network based data that's a
really good question uh the use cases
that I've seen were came from I
understand it to primarily be about file
based data but the thing is I mean files
and strings are the same thing so if you
can figure out a way to ship this to
other devices other processes it's the
same
thing one
you
so the question was what are default
values what are they using for so it
turns out that if you're saving many
objects again going back to the game
example let's say you've got hundreds of
players or maybe
particles having default values let to
save a lot of space because their entry
actually doesn't even exist in the wire
format if the value isn't default the
generated code knows that it can detect
that field is missing and it'll Supply
you the default value that you put in
your
schema so it allows you to it's almost I
think there are other formats that will
compress runs of zeros for you this is
sort of a more advanced version of the
same idea where any value that is the
same across many instances will be not
so far okay can you talk about what's in
the first 20 bytes the offer and the
metad data yeah so a flat can have more
than one object and
so uh this gives the offset to sort of
the root object it forms a tree in the
file it's just in Cas it's only
full the question was it's 64
bits why that seems very long I may have
uh skipped a detail there I think
there's actually another
value there's one right behind you yeah
um so just going back to the the
variable l
that's how so if you had a an array or a
list of these objects you would just
have all of the all the names basically
at the end of that list or is it's kind
of interesting so the name String
metadata there uh is just an offset that
tells you where to
locate the actual string right
so when it's being read generated code
just calculates that so you can put it
anywhere you want
right but in order to quickly like
iterate through this list would you you
would basically just have offsets for
the objects so so the question was you
know what kind of I think localities
keeps going what kind of locality can
you get if you put all the strings in
this example at the end if you any of
these you always be hopping back and
forth to where you are and then where
the strs are is that sort of what you're
saying sort of yeah I me where's the
efficiency is or do you use like that
you just grab like the longest string
and that's how wide your string is for
all of them uh did you actually go back
to the
generator one
more
this so you can see how we create the
string in one function call the order in
which we do these function calls
determines the order in which they end
up in the final clap fin so if you put
all of your strings at the end it would
look like a bunch of create string
begin because the builds come back to
the but if you wanted them to be inter
leave you would just do name then object
then name object does that answer your
question there's freedom in how you lay
it out yeah all
right do you know anything about how FL
is compared to the go format that's in
the ghost
Library I can't really speak to that I
will say one thing which is that an
issue she was raised on a flat buffers
uh GitHub uh that asked can we make this
fit into the interface uh for the
encoding package and go and uh my
response you know I love to hear a
better way to do it my understanding at
the time was that because you have a
schema and it's not in line in the
data you need a separate way to inform
the consumer
more
those are great questions this is
exactly what I hope would
have
go
so philosophy is simple flat buffers
generates code that uses just a few
jumps to get to anything that you would
want we use pointer arithmetic to skip
what's a traditionally par step entirely
speed part
two so it's not just mobile devices and
it's not just
games every computer is resource
constrained at scale inefficiencies add
up to tremendous amounts of energy time
and money
wasted again if you have hundreds
thousands of machines and you can shave
off tens of percents of time uh that's a
big
deal
so flat buffers can help in
that and again what the Benchmark said
we're also happy
about and now that you've learned a
little bit more about this are there any
questions about the
benchmarks which are micro
benchmarks so there are more
reasons fast and also supports scheme of
verin Union Fields default values which
we spoke about earlier inline structs
variable L vectors also spoke about
those before uh it is very robust uh and
it's C++
implementation and C Java and go are
less mature and Rising quickly we're
looking we're looking for more languages
to support uh and as you'll see in the
slider to the run time is very small so
if anybody has another language they
would like to add uh now's the time to
do
it
so over 2200 GitHub Stars uh the code is
just small like I said it's minimal for
what it does and it's I think it's very
very nicely written um the wire format
stable it's been confirmed to be
identical in four different language
implementations a lot of tests F tests
which are one of my favorite things and
I want to emphasize again how few lines
of code there are so C C++ that
generates
C++ that generates
the all the uh code for different
languages as well as a C++
implementation itself is under 5,000
lines of code and then the go run time
that you have to import whenever you
construct flat
buffers is less than a thousand lines of
code so the ideas have been distilled to
the very
small so if you wanted to say audit flat
buffers for use case you would look at
the C++ code and it header files and go
run time and you would be looking at
5,000 lines of code that's
it so go use it there's tons of
documentation there's a white paper
there are benchmarks um a lot of
motivation for why the project exists
the source code is open you can go
install the rtime library right now on
your laptop and you can go check out the
uh schema compiler at the
Flory so
thanks I should ask all
questions so the question was given that
these are biased micro benchmarks could
we have structured protocol up as
example to uh have been much more
perform yeah I think the answer the
answer that is always yes
I don't mean to kind of skip the
question
but gu
from so the question is what what is
flat buffers less efficient at than its
peers I'm not prepared to answer that
question I think it's a great one and if
you want to write documentation that
goes into that I think we find
[Music]
so I've seen the benchmarks right and uh
I'm aware I think there are two more
libraries that have this similar feature
that they don't do any uh allocations
for reading uh I think it's g go PR and
Captain
PR can you compare uh flers to this how
do they differ so the the statement was
uh there are other libraries that are
atically similar to Flat buffers one of
which is Captain Proto and what was the
other one I think it's go goo if I'm not
mistaken so go go Proto the Google go
protuff library is go Proto and uh the
optimized version of that is go go
protocol
yeah just to
finish there are other libraries go
Proto buff is from Google and go go
protuff is a f version of that um so
there actually there documentation on a
flater site that addresses those things
the most direct comparison is with
Captain Proto uh it was found that the
uh scheme of vering capabilities excuse
me the scheme of vering capabilities of
C Proto were not enough to meet the
needs of the Android developers who got
this started and also the code was not
Visual Studio compatible and so they had
major compatibility
issues do you know anything about the
performance characteristics how do they
compare the question was do I know
anything about the performance
characteristics versus uh these other uh
protocols
um I don't have the numbers yeah there
was another question back there y um
how's support for RPC and specifically
thec
libr
by so the question was what's the
support like for RPC which are remote
procedure calls and specifically how
does it relate to the go RPC Library
um point I think the way I would answer
that is that this is how you transmit
data and you understand how to interpret
it that's at a lower level what you
choose to do with that data if you
interpret it as a function call or
something else uh is at a higher level I
guess I CU um if it's already in the
library there's support like a for using
it with a RPC
pack so so the question was this
integrated with kind of the standard go
interfaces for network communication the
answer is no that's forthcoming we're
still figur out how to do that in the
best way
possible great thank you so much
everyone I love all the
questions